Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Qui n’a jamais porté un masque
par nécessité ou par obligation
pour affronter telle ou telle situation ?
Moi, j'en ai porté toute ma vie.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Lorsque j’étais enfant, dans la loge de
gardienne de ma mère, gare du Nord,
je passais mon temps à essayer d’effacer
tous les stigmates
de ma condition sociale.
Rien ne devait paraître.
Je devais gommer toutes les aspérités
pour pouvoir faire croire
au monde extérieur
que j’étais comme tout le monde
avec une enfance normale.
Je devais faire croire que j’étais
une enfant sans problème.
Est-ce que ça a un sens ?
Pour nous, les enfants descendants
d’immigrés, bien plus que pour les autres,
nous avons une sommation non négociable
à ne pas exister aussi bien à l’intérieur
de nos familles qu’à l’extérieur.
Une sommation
à s’invisibiliser,
à presque disparaître,
finalement à n’être personne.
Savez-vous que « personne »
vient du latin « persona » ?
Dans le théâtre de la Rome antique,
il s’agit en fait d’un masque
que l’acteur portait
pour incarner le personnage
qu’il interprétait.
Moi, à ce moment-là,
j’interprétais la fille discrète
de la concierge.
Ensuite arriva le moment
des études à la fac.
Là, je passais mon temps
à cacher le fait que je n’avais pas
les moyens de me payer des livres.
Vous l’aurez compris, non seulement
ma situation ne s’était pas améliorée,
mais elle s’était dégradée.
En effet, entre temps,
j’ai quitté mes parents
pour qui les études avaient
bien moins d’intérêt
qu’un mariage de raison.
Alors, je peux vous dire que les cafés
avec mes petits camarades -
cinq francs - de la rue Soufflot -
ce n’était pas pour moi.
Je prétextais régulièrement
des rendez-vous ailleurs.
Tout ça pour un seul but :
ne pas montrer dans quel état j’étais,
pouvoir intégrer ce système
en essayant de faire croire aux autres
qu’en fait, je venais du même milieu.
Je ne vous raconte pas, quel casse-tête !
Combien d’ingéniosité
déployée pour ça !
À ce moment-là, on peut dire
que je jouais le rôle
de la fille « normale »
étudiante en philosophie.
Alors, pour apaiser
toute cette schizophrénie,
la psychanalyse s’est invitée dans ma vie
par le biais d’un professeur
de sociologie.
Grâce à lui, j’ai su, par exemple,
que Carl Jung avait conceptualisé
la persona
comme un masque social
que met l’individu sur son visage
et qui, au fur et à mesure,
altère son identité.
Comme le dit Sénèque,
« il n’est pas de vent favorable
pour celui qui ne sait pas où il va. »
Moi, j’ai eu cette chance, c’est que,
dès le départ, je savais où j’allais.
Au cours de mon travail analytique,
j’ai réussi à dompter les évitements
car j’avais vraiment
en face de moi un seul but :
ma rencontre avec moi-même.
Pouvez-vous me dire s’il y a une rencontre
plus intéressante, plus belle ?
Le sport a été très important pour moi.
En particulier, la boxe.
J'ai choisi ce sport par atavisme.
Et ça complétait exactement ma démarche.
Dans ce noble art,
donner ses tripes s’impose
à chaque instant.
Le combat que je pensais mener
contre un adversaire,
finalement, était un combat
contre moi-même.
À chaque fois,
ou je faisais jaillir de ce chaos
en moi une étoile dansante,
ou je finissais à terre par un KO.
Peu importe l’issue du scénario,
finalement, l’essentiel pour moi,
c’étaient les émotions ressenties,
et à travers ces émotions,
toutes ces étapes franchies avec brio.
À ce moment-là, vraiment, j’ai ressenti,
comme le disait Aimé Césaire,
que « l’heure de moi-même avait sonné ».
J'étais enfin prête, je voulais me
réaliser, je savais où je voulais aller.
C'était la police nationale pour pouvoir
aider les gens et être utile au monde.
Très vite,
j’ai compris qu’il fallait
que je découvre une nouvelle identité
qu’on m’assenait comme ça,
qui est l’identité de la beurette.
Rien que de prononcer ce mot,
cela m’écorche les lèvres.
Y a-t-il plus péjoratif ?
Là, j’ai définitivement pris
conscience d’une chose :
toute ma vie,
j’allais être assignée à des identités.
Et ça,
au gré des subjectivités des uns,
des fantasmes des autres.
Alors, que faire ?
Me laisser envahir ?
Sûrement pas.
Il fallait que je fasse bloc,
que je ressaisisse, que je rassemble,
toutes les facettes de mon identité
et que je les assume
envers et contre tous.
Alors, je continuais mon petit chemin.
En sécurité publique,
gardien de la paix,
ensuite dans un service spécialisé
dans les violences urbaines.
Tranquillement, sereinement.
Jusqu’à ce qu’arrive le 11 septembre 2001.
À ce moment, le monde bascule.
Le terrorisme
entre dans une nouvelle ère.
Je suis contactée un soir
par la direction centrale
des Renseignements généraux.
Moi, Nora.
Je suis appelée
pour être la première fille à intégrer un
service de filature et de surveillance
dédié à la lutte
contre le terrorisme islamiste.
Je suis sidérée.
J'y crois à peine.
Aujourd’hui encore, je ne pourrais même
pas vous dire pourquoi j’ai été choisie.
Le fait est
que je l’ai été.
On m’explique que j’ai un week-end
pour me préparer à une mission.
Lundi matin, nous devons partir
pour aller filocher, comme on dit
chez nous - c’est-à-dire surveiller -
un des plus grands terroristes qui
se prépare à commettre un attentat.
En un week-end, je vais aller vite
me procurer mes apparats :
mon voile, ma djellaba,
mon oreillette.
Oreillette qu’il faut
véritablement bien maîtriser,
car il suffit que vous la fassiez tomber
et la filature, c’est fini.
Lorsque j’ai enfilé ma djellaba,
il fallait aussi pouvoir être capable
d’atteindre l’arme rapidement, au cas où.
Comme j’étais la première fille,
aucun conseil féminin pour gérer
et une robe et une arme.
Mais on trouve toujours des ressources
dans ces moments-là
et je vous assure que j’étais tellement
fière de servir mon pays
que j’ai réussi à trouver tous les
stratagèmes pour bien m’équiper.
Alors, me voilà en filature, en mission.
Un jour, les cheveux attachés ;
un jour, les cheveux longs ;
un jour, avec des lunettes ;
Un jour, sans ;
un jour, en jogging ; un jour, en parlant
arabe ; un jour, en parlant français.
Bref, je jouais le rôle
d’un agent du renseignement
au service de la France.
Alors, j'en ai fait des filatures,
j'en ai fait.
Je me suis tellement posé de questions,
puisque, de toute façon,
je ne peux rien faire
sans intellectualiser.
Je me disais en regardant
ces gens, ces objectifs :
« Qu’est-ce qu’ils peuvent
bien penser de moi
derrière tous ces apparats ? »
Eh bien, figurez-vous que
je n’ai pas eu à attendre longtemps,
puisque c’est le terroriste lui-même qui
est venu me voir et m’apporter la réponse.
Je n’en attendais pas autant.
J'étais de mission filature.
J'étais avec ma djellaba, mon voile.
Il vient me voir
et il me dit : « Vous,
je sais qui vous êtes.
Vous êtes un agent du renseignement.
Vous avez beaucoup de courage
et beaucoup d’énergie,
mais vous commettez une grave erreur :
vous servez des gens qui ne seront jamais
reconnaissants envers vous
et qui ne vous considéreront
jamais comme une des leurs.
Vous ne serez jamais considérée
comme une Française.
Arrêtez de vous raconter des histoires.
En revanche, vous êtes une musulmane.
Vous êtes comme moi, vous êtes comme nous.
Et nous,
vous ferez toujours partie
de notre famille.
Alors, choisissez bien votre camp. »
À ce moment-là,
je touche du doigt le moment fatidique,
ce point de bascule
par lequel beaucoup de jeunes
se sont orientés vers la radicalisation
violente et le terrorisme.
Ces jeunes-là ont cru à cette tirade,
ce moment précis
qu’on vous renvoie à la figure,
ce moment d’identité bousculée,
remise en question.
Je le regarde.
Je m'en éloigne et je repense à tout ça.
Je me dis : « Voilà.
Même un terroriste
se permet de me dire qui je suis. »
Alors, vous voyez,
avec ou sans masque,
on ne peut rien y faire,
on essaiera toujours de nous enfermer,
de nous catégoriser.
Et là,
j’en ai vraiment assez.
C'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui,
je me révèle à vous.
Oui, je suis Nora Lakheal.
Devant vous.
Je suis un ancien agent
du renseignement français.
J’ai risqué ma vie pour servir
ce pays et j’en suis très fière.
Et si j’enlève ce masque en prenant
tous les risques que ça implique -
car cela implique des risques -
c’est pour une seule raison :
c’est pour vous apporter ce message.
Ne vous laissez pas enfermer
dans des catégories.
Une identité, ce n’est pas quelque chose
qui est donné, qui est figé.
Une identité, ça se construit.
C'est en pleine évolution,
c'est un processus.
Peut-être que dans quelques années,
nous allons nous revoir.
Je le sais, je serai encore
quelqu’un d’autre.
Mais on ne pourra jamais m’enlever le fait
que je suis la somme
de toutes les femmes
que j’ai été depuis ma naissance.
Alors,
je conclurai
en citant cette phrase de Paul Éluard :
« Parce que nous naissons de partout,
nous sommes infinis. »
Merci.